Newland Harbor at the southern tip of
corn whoo these trawlers usually land
fish that ends up in the world's finest
restaurants but no more as soon as the
pandemic reached reached a point where
borders were being closed for the
fishing industry that was stopped from
that moment
Jeromy Hoskin is a third-generation
fisherman he should be out catching
lobster and crab as little boats were
just started in our season we've just
been through a really poor winter we
haven't worked very much for five or six
months we're just about to begin what we
would normally expect do and obviously
this pandemic has has come right at that
moment so we've gone a long period of
time with the with no income and now
we've got another period that we really
don't know where the incomes gonna come
from usually this is one of the UK's
busiest fishing ports but it's dead
there are very few boats operational and
without the restaurants and the
associated trade this industry is
becoming increasingly impossible but
there is a glimmer of hope is pandemic
has actually created a new opportunity
for Cornwall's fishermen well this is
turret from newly market this morning
kasia's payne says the virus stopped his
business overnight he needed to act
quickly
the Cornish fish produces organization
launched fish to your door and the
waters just keep on coming well we get
in families audio and direct to the
house people have started cooking again
you know goes back to basics basically
what we was doing years ago you know get
rid of all these ready meals oh it's pop
home food good wholesome food fresh
straight from the sea next day within 24
hours it's like your house
while some can adapt others have been
forced to close
Padstow on the north coast
this holiday whether it should be packed
it looks and sounds like never before
[Music]
right across Cornwall the Sun is out but
the county is deserted
what would the path normally be like
forgotten Joey full of children running
around having a great time
shows characters different by the camel
Creek Adventure Park has furloughed
around a hundred and thirty staff
usually they'd be looking after 3,000
visitors a day there is no one playing
there is no laughter there are no
memories being made it is eerie isn't it
if you ever seen it like this no of
course not not not even during the
winter not even during the refurbishment
time we would have staff numbers
everywhere painting brushing cleaning
getting the park ready so it's it's very
very strange it feels abandoned and it's
like this at attractions across the
county all they could do is prepare and
hope it's really is about making sure we
got a plan a and a plan B and Plan C for
any eventuality as to when the park will
be reopened and last when the rules will
start to to be relaxed it's real isn't
it it is Aurilia yeah it is daunting
at this time of year tourism would see
Cornwall's population increase by around
a third that this virus shut the
industry down all agree the lockdown is
essential there is a greater fear
tourists must return for July and August
the peak months and there's a stark
warning if they can't for the worst-case
scenario which we hope will never happen
this went through to two walkers we'd be
talking about 1.2 billion pounds worth
of loss and that will that will be the
end for some it was according to our
research from the end of 80% of the
businesses there should be thousands of
holidaymakers here right now enjoying
this site but it's locked down it is
empty there is nobody here this is the
biggest test for Cornwall's tourism
sector but even in this adversity sites
like this and doing what they can to
help those on the front line Hendra
Holiday Park in Newquay is making its
caravans available to key workers who
need to isolate holiday let's across the
county are being offered up Hannah
Dobson is a care worker that calls only
major hospital both her parents are
classed as vulnerable and it's just 18
she decided to move out of home for the
first time she was given a holiday cabin
by a local family I've been completely
used to just being all like mom and dad
can do my washing and things like that
and not having to go like from having it
one week and then the next week
completely you are on your own now
I'm kind of like learning within Albert
yeah it's I'm so grateful for the
accommodation that I've been given like
so so so grateful that I'm able to still
work and my parents are safe as well
the coronavirus has left Cornwall empty
and silent
for many all they can do is wait the
tourists will return the beaches will be
full again but the fear is it could be
too late for some damn whited Sky News
in Cornwall